people like me i was born in a very poor  family i never got a great education  you know i filled all the examinations  for what reason i don't know  but  later i realized i don't have money i  don't have technology i don't have a lot  of good backgrounds we have a rich uncle  or something no  the only thing i compete with my people  than young people is let's compete for  10 years later  this is what i believe 10 years later  will be happening so everything i do for  that girl i know  10 years later this thing is going to  happen so prepare for that  because i know if i compete with him for  next month no chance  so this is how my message is up it's a  challenge but it's opportunity  and it's the opportunity for people like  us